yeah hello everybody didn't expect that
many people to my first days unconscious
talk
over here yeah hacking games and why
should you do it
most of us started learning programming
by ourselves at home reading books or
magazines and then the internet came and
we learned everything there and but I
think we can agree on that we actually
learn the most while we are debugging
and searching from box and browsing the
code and really try to understand what
we actually did there because while
we're coding we kind of know what we're
doing and we just type it down in the
end everything works we're happy and
never see the file again and yeah and I
also really like games and what I do in
my free time is except fun apart from
programming games I check out games
online and try to see their code and how
they solve the problems they had and how
I can manipulate that to my advantage so
what do you see here this is a game I
actually made myself kind of a
proof-of-concept thing I made this back
when this candy box thing went why were
probably you know that game where you
get candy and you can eat all the candy
and then you get a sword and you get
quests and the Frog comes and you can
answer all the questions and so what do
you have to do here it's a very simple
game the goal is to become a millionaire
and you have 20 gold and you can mine
gold so it's a classic clicker game and
it's also an idol game because you can
use your goal gold to buy a miner
so here's Pete he's just working in the
mind and every 5 gold or so he puts his
gold into my pocket and he's working and
he has an efficiency and I can use my
goal to upgrade Pete or I can use my
gold
- hi another miner so if I don't want to
wait and so Peter is has mined all the
gold I just click here very rapidly and
now I buy a second miner and click again
again ok that's a hundred that takes too
much time now I'm already bored and I
want the game to progress faster so what
do I do
first thing is I check the sources so
there's a JavaScript folder and there's
an index.html that's the easiest way to
start just go there and check for any
scripts so there's one script check
loading required yes
and data - loading the edges so I might
want to check out the fjs not to game.js
where's the FJ jeaious asd there's no HS
so maybe it's the game J's maybe I don't
know my code as well so I checked the
code in a browser code and I can set
some breakpoints of course that would be
the easiest approach or I can check if
there's something like access to the
window object when a game object to
store this is obviously on purpose yeah
but the much more easier approaches I
know I can click this button to get some
gold so why don't I just inspect it and
see if it has an ID or it has an ID and
just take that and hopefully jQuery is
installed and looks like it is I have to
code with one hand now that's a little
bit difficult like that okay I get it
and I can run the click function did it
work
and it looks like it works okay now the
tricky stuff set interval and then I
pass in a function and then I take the
button like that and and I do click and
because I don't want to wait that long
ah there's the syntax error I just don't
pass any value into the set interval
function with Mason on really fast and
now I get all the goals I want and I can
buy all the - I need and now I just have
to wait okay I actually came depending
on my memory on my local machine I can
run this couple times more
and those increases Madchester and now
apparently I got all the minor so now I
can work on the efficiency so they are
better at mining but still now we would
wait like ten minutes to get all them 1
million and actually tested it when you
only have the - and you don't cheat and
you have all the - and no efficiency
upgrade it takes like 24 hours for them
to mine all the 1 million but that's
obviously too much time so what can we
do we know we have to become a
millionaire
and we already check the source and so
that oh there's the PETA object in the
window so you might want to inspect that
Pete so it looks like a backbone view
because it obviously is and what do I
have you have an event lock I don't care
for that I have improvements or whatever
I never saw that actually that's a
feature I put in and then put it out
again so we don't care for that I have
miners which is an area where all my -
restored but I don't care for them
because they're too slow and their stats
Oh instead looks very nice so I have a
back size probably the size of the
miners and when they put their gold into
my storage don't care much for that and
I have the state of my current gold this
is very nice so let me quickly reload
that to make it more obvious what
happens now I can use Pete and then
stats this is the third subject I could
easily try to say oh there's a one
property I put it to true and what
happens next
hmm seems like nothing happened except
that I can't really do anything
so probably the games check that I win
that didn't make a proper response what
else can I do
there's gold ah that sounds nice so Pete
dot stats dot gold equals nine nine nine
nine nine zero okay that worked
obviously and now I try to click it for
ten times I have the patience for that
actually nice I won the game very good I
don't have to play it anymore I know all
the features but that's something I
programmed myself that was pretty easy
to hack now try a real example I already
talked about candy box there's when you
first load the page you only see
and is increasing over time and suddenly
there appears a baton where I can eat
all the candy and nothing happened
except for a text that I ate nine
candies and on my first try of this game
I just clicked it over and over again in
the hope that something would change but
actually nothing changed you have to
wait until they're like a hundred
candies and the next button appears and
the game kinda explode from there you
get more and more features or I can
throw pennies on the ground I can do
that much more often and sometimes there
will be a unhappy smiley face there and
it changes depending on how many candy
you can throw on the ground you throw on
the ground so but I don't want to wait
here and I want to improve that as well
so I check the sources again and see
there's a scripts folder and there's
lots of streets so many scripts so when
I come to a situation where I have that
many scripts I try something else first
because most game developers to be able
to debug their game while it's running
and to manipulator to test if
everything's working they expose the
game object like I did with Pete so I
check for game what's the first thing I
do
there's no game unfortunately maybe
they've got clever and had the capital G
but that nah doesn't seem to work as
well so I'm screwed and I have to check
the source again and check for something
candies candy sounds very good because I
get candies and I would assume that
something happening where the candies is
in the candies J s and here in the
script I see that the bar statement for
the candies object is directly in the
file so I know it's on the global scope
and I try that out and let's see if
there's actually a candy and there is a
candies object so what do I got here and
that console suck I got candies per
second oh that sounds very interesting
let's try that
candies dot candies per second equals 2
1 3 3 7 marvelous so I don't want to
wait that long so try to explore that a
little bit and make the game progress
first there's the merchants you have to
wait until you got Hoonah candies so in
that 100 I can buy the wooden sword now
and the couple sword and the iron sword
and the service hole in the diamond
sword I can use 101 candies to encrust
it and now in my inventory I have the
candy diamond sword usually for the
first quest peaceful forest I only have
to kill trees the wooden sword would be
enough but it is much more faster with
them and so because they immediately die
and I can progress through the quests
the extra goal is to beat all the quests
there's like 14 quest I think and
there's even one quest where the end
pose is the developer I only beat that
level by putting a breakpoint into the
game and setting the HP of the developer
to zero but it worked and since the coat
is so nice and clean and not mini fight
and it obfuscated it's very easy to to
heck obviously the developer of that
game realized that and made some
improvements and candy box too so this
is the sequel to candy box and it's
basically the same game there's lots of
more features and some changes in the
game and if we check these sources again
we find the candy box to J's so oh [ __ ]
that will take more time to heck
actually but on chrome there's this nice
button in the left here called pretty
print and pretty print pretty prints
obfuscated code so it's better readable
it doesn't change the variable names
unless you get access to the net file
unfortunately I don't have access to the
nab file because the deployed version of
the JavaScript doesn't include the death
map tech which is very good for him
obviously he realized that something or
she that players hacked the game and
yeah and now I can start putting
breakpoints on here and beat the game as
well but I don't want to export the
second candy box I just want to actually
want to show you another game cookie
clicker probably many of you know the
game cookie clicker
come on obviously this is some safe game
no I don't want to can i reset the game
somewhere settings options options wipe
very good do it okay cuca click has a
very nice game
there's the cookie you click it you get
the cookie
and when you have 15 cookies to get a
cursor which means now I get zero point
one cookie per second and I can click
over and open open open oval again and I
can buy a second cursor when I have 100
cookies I get the grandma and then I get
the factory and the cookie farm and some
quantum physics operating machine who
does like a trillion cookies a second
but you know me I'm not very patient
when it comes to games I want to see
everything right away and I tried the
first thing again which I did with the
Pete game yeah I check out the button
and then for fortunately this is a just
plain hot email HTML and JavaScript
flash games are not that easy to hack
you would need to like use some kind of
tool for that but I don't like that
and yeah this is a button again with the
IDE and I think we can try out if I am
able to do the same trick I did with
Pete so I have the jQuery here right yes
and then now we get the big cookie and
that works as well and I can click it I
can click it so the rest is easy set
interval German keyboards
boom nice so that is very good but yeah
the achievements are popping all over
this place I'm so good I get all the
achievements and now I can buy a time
directly without having to have a
grandma but you can imagine there's
quite some objects here and the list
grows and grows it only shows you the
next two so I'm patient as I am let's
check the source code if we can speed
this process up there's some main.js and
the main J s is quite some fire lots of
lines were your markup game code
interesting game girls and they all
explain very nice thank you very much
cookies earn cookies cookies PS is
probably cookies per second cookie
frenzy frenzy max power clique frenzy
golden cliques sometimes there appears
like a golden thingy here and I can
click it and I get some extra cookies
but what I'm actually interested in is
if there's the possibility to manipulate
the buildings directly instead of you
know clicking the button automatically
so let's check out the console if we
have some kind of game object again okay
that's a diff container don't care for
that oh and there is a game object is it
the right one let's see oh that looks
very nice so what do we got here we got
big cookie sighs we got can click
interesting so there's obviously some
kind of cheat prevention maybe this gets
set to zero when you click so that it's
preventing you from clicking thousands
of times per second but obviously it
doesn't do the job very good
and let's see objects by ID what's that
how to clicks once every 10 seconds
cursor so that's obviously the buildings
and there's 14 of them so the best
podium probably is the last one
and the array and the numbers look quite
nice they're in very many zeroes the
prism converts light itself into cookies
yeah that's what I'm going for but to
make sure what are the values I can set
so there is an amount and there is
bought and attract us once if you only
update one of those values it does
nothing because the game internally
checks and match see if those numbers
match to see if the user cheated so what
we have to do is we have to increase
both of them okay let's try that so it
was game object by ID then we got 14 so
I need 13 and then amount equals some
crazy biggest number and then the same
number for game object 13.4 and I think
I broke it
yeah happens from time to time oh snap
if you get too crazy with the numbers
the game's kind of crash so maybe we try
a thousand that works much better and
the achievements are rolling in again so
let's quickly just close it see if
everything's correct
I get the prism a thousand times great
and I get two point nine trillion
cookies per second
that's something I can work with for my
next game anyone here working at game
porch no great anyone working at big
point you would like that no okay I used
to work at both the next game is Oh game
this is a very classic browser game
which actually works with PHP which
means most of the clicks you do trigger
a refresh of the page which is very
unfortunate because I cannot run myself
interval stuff or anything like that
because if I actually do an interaction
with the game the page gets reloaded my
script is gone and to of course when the
page is reloaded this request to the
server they validate stuff you do so
there's not much to actually sheet to
progress in the game and that's good
because that's a multiplayer game and
singer player games developers users
don't care about preventing players to
cheat because why should they there is
no competition with other players and
you don't necessarily need to prevent
the cheating thing unless you have
something like a competition which is
where you collect the stats and you see
okay the best player of my game actually
wins something then you want to prevent
cheating but unless you don't have that
don't care about it people will do it
anyway
there's the cheat engine where you can
read the memory stats and it's a waste
of time if you just do a single player
game and for this game I had to actually
play it a little bit I played the back
in 2000 I don't know 4 or something
because there's one thing in the game
which gets really annoying this is a
game and the
in a universe where you have planets and
you can build on the planets and minds
and chips and then you can take your
fleet and attack other players and
there's one thing you do very often you
get those planets here and they also
produce resources but usually you build
your fleet on your main planet so what
you do is you click on the planet page
goods reloaded you click on the fleet
button page gets reloaded you select the
ships you want to send and click on next
page gets reloaded you check a short
link for the planet and back in the days
those didn't exist it you have to type
the coordinates manually pain in the ass
and then you click again Paige gets
reloaded and you are no right I have to
choose the nation so transport select
all the resources and then I can click
flutter to then sending my fleet to the
extra planet so what about what I did
here I know that I cannot use the other
script and just paste it in and it will
do the magic because there the page
reloads but I know that I can manipulate
bookmarks if you have a bookmark and you
just type JavaScript and then you can
add JavaScript code there I use this
very often to prevent Google from when
you search on Google sometimes they
notice you that they have new TOS or
something with the overlay and you have
to agree to them unless you don't want
to use Google anymore and I have the
bookmark which actually removes the
entire div and I can just continue
search without ever agreeing so the new
terms of service which is very nice I
think I'm on the TOS from melon or four
years ago and I did the same here so I
have three bookmarks the first is fleet
one fleet one just selects all my
transport ships and clicks Next and it
doesn't actually just click Next there
is a function they expose the globe
scope because the game is mostly written
in PHP but they have some JavaScript
functions there to help them make it a
little bit more dynamic like to the
accounts and stuff and they also have to
try submit function the global scope
which is used on the fleets screen to
actually
try to submit their javascript form and
you can use that so I just click send
all and then call the function try
separate and that work I'm on the next
screen next step is the fleet to
bookmark and can you read through that
Yeah right
so I select the span from the planets
with the anchor and then click it which
actually does this little short thing
here then the selection pops out and I
select after that the ul initialized L
II which is the first element of the
list you have to do the inspecting for
that and then again try the try sublet
button and it works and then for the
last screen I do the set selected
function this is another public function
for the mission select then the next
thing is the update mission one thing
the first first part in here the set
selected just renders around an orange
box around the transport and the next
one actually clicks it and then usually
when you click it this opens and you can
fill the bellies and there's buttons
here for automatically setting all the
resources and if you're very good at
looking you can see the change oh and if
I'm good at clicking you can actually
see the change you see the numbers get
filled in and my fleet is underway
usually if you do all this process by
hand it takes up to five minutes sending
all your ships from all your sub planets
to your main planet and you can have up
to twelve planets so it will take up a
significant amount of time while you
play and I don't want to wait especially
if I get attacked to get attacked I want
to save all my fleets immediately and
what I just do is I select the planet
and then I just click fleet one fleet
two three three and select plate three
and select the next planet and why
should you do that why should you heck
the games because you learn a lot on how
other other game developers or
developers in general solve their
problems how
try to prevent cheating and there's a
nice example in drips that that's
another Idol game the last one I show
you today any one of you writes Java you
will like that maybe a lot so this is a
memory leak Idol game now you create new
objects to leak memory and once you have
leaked enough you can drop the memory
and there's actually multiplayer
involved where people are compared to
each other depending on how much memory
they have leaked and what the game
actually supports I don't know if we
will be able to see this is that you can
connect a virtual machine to that game
which does all the heavy lifting for you
like clicking and stuff so quickly try
to do the little heck with a click event
button at memory console and again what
was it
bitten at something BTN - admin button -
add you here yes can I click you as a
perk is there another thing in there
No Oh doesn't work anymore I used to
work that's it okay you could now
technically inspector JavaScript and
find the button there's also a Chrome
extension which cheats for you it
because you can also buy the upgrades
here for the cursors and everything
which clicks automatically and there's
like the perfect path you can go
depending on when do you spend your
memory on upgrades and when you just
drip it and everything and this thing
does everything for you and if you are
too crazy about the sheeting and I think
I had like 25 set intervals running on
the click button sometime and then
suddenly the page showed me hey it looks
like you're cheating please reload the
page once you reload the page you're
back to the beginning and have to click
again yeah so I think this was
everything I wanted to show you
and I want to encourage you to hack the
games police is not here yet that's very
good so we have time for questions thank
you
this ability to set the coordinates
where you have to click or different
technically you could read the
coordinates from the page and then just
menu it trigger a click event there
which is not that easy because to
actually trigger manually manual click
events you have to dispatch them to a
element and then the element itself is
clicked not just a spot in the element
so it is quite tricky without extensions
to click in flash games but there is a
thing called the cheat engine you have
to deactivate your antivirus software
for that because of kind of acts like a
Trojan horse
and this lets you reach memory from
tasks used from processes you select and
what you do is you go on the game you
take a number for example your gold and
you put that number like you have 500
gold you put that into the cheat engine
and then it lists you all the
information cut where the number 500 us
and you go back in the game again and
spend some of your gold and then you put
that number you have left like 250 back
in the memory and then you get a
filtered list from your previous memory
addresses and the next memory addresses
and then you compare those and then you
find a memory entry where the gold is
actually stored and then you can
manipulate it and go back in the game
and well last see that there's the
different amount but in flash games like
I said it's much mahalo and usually they
have something like cached game stats
which they compare on each tick to see
if the user is cheating because you can
easily calculate how many gold you can
get per tick or something like that and
but it works for most of the games on
Kongregate and armor games and stuff
like that
I was thinking about how to find the
velvet ice and constantly yeah it
depends again if it is single-player
multiplayer if it does multiplayer you
have to do some serious stuff to prevent
this and there is back-end checks of
course to do that you can also do like
hashes of your game stats which you
store somewhere deep in your game and
then compare those for single-player
games I wouldn't really care if you
really want to care there's multiple
ways you can use the local storage you
can if you run on the in Chrome they
have an open database where you can have
a little SQL database but the problem
the browser is that the user always has
access to everything you cannot hide
something from the user only in the
browser
right and that's something you don't
want to you don't want to use us to have
kind of experience reloading the page
every time you click like in the old
game yeah but still they take time and
in those idle games usually very fast
yeah
and then you risk getting a decent and
you have two states one of the front end
a different from the back end and that
kind of feels like cheating to the back
end because the user was too fast and
have to be very careful with that to not
ruin the user experience because and
when when your website breaks people
usually reload the page if you game
breaks people usually throw it away and
take the next game yeah sure feel free
to talk to me and add me on Twitter if
you want to know more about that stuff
Luka JEP oh maybe I can quickly open it
and you can see the name
hopefully other it's very small there
Luke like Skywalker and TEP like TEP
like TCP yeah thank you
you